this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
hey wisecrack jared here coming from
these self isolating comforts of my own
apartment and let me tell you I got a
bad feeling about this
no I'm not just talking about my dueling
supplies of top ramen and coffee but
well this I have a bad feeling about
this
yes the time has finally come to delve
into the least controversial subject on
the internet a little yarn called Star
Wars when the rise of Skywalker was set
for release director JJ Abrams promised
this final entry in the Saga would tie
up everything that had come before heard
the filmmaker this wasn't just the end
of a single movie or even a trilogy it
was the end of an entire nine film saga
it had to be the end of not just three
movies but nine movies the question of
course could the rise of Skywalker
possibly tie up every loose end and
story thread in a satisfying way I mean
this is a gargantuan seemingly
impossible task and yet somehow they did
it after the film's release the rise of
Skywalker was lauded as the best Star
Wars film of all time and the internet
came together in Universal celebration
oh wait sorry I was imagining an
alternate timeline we're going out to
the grocery store isn't an episode of
black mirror no the rise of Skywalker
was of course a colossal disappointment
filled with awkward exposition plot
holes and strange retconning of its
predecessors so what the hell happened
how did the rise of Skywalker fail so
absolutely well the answer lies in the
past you know that thing the last film
kind of sort of tried to kill but the
past time
kill it if you have to so welcome to
this wise pack edition on the rise of
Skywalker what went wrong and of course
spoilers ahead for the whole Skywalker
saga but before we get into it I want to
give a shout out to this week's sponsor
keeps it could be hard to admit that
you're losing your hair especially when
in my case it's pretty intertwined with
my identity it's tough to talk about but
ignoring it won't solve the problem with
hair loss prevention is key
two out of three eyes will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 and although I'm
praying I'm the one out of three it's
best to be sure keeps is an affordable
hair loss treatment plan that brings
fda-approved prescription and
over-the-counter medication right to
your door their treatments can combat
hair loss so you keep the hair on your
head
with keep some men even experienced hair
regrowth you can meet with a keeps
doctor right from the comfort of your
own home from there you can order your
treatments and keep track of your
progress
find out why keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
why'd nearly 100,000 men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention medication by
clicking the link in the description or
by going to keeps calm / wisecrack if
you use our link you can get 50% off
your first order so stop stressing about
your hair and now back to the show
alright let's get into a quick recap the
rise of Skywalker begins with the
resistance intercepting a message that
Palpatine is somehow not only alive and
well but amassing a fleet of ships on
the hidden planet x achill our heroes
rey finn and Poe go in search of a
Wayfinder that will lead to the
mysterious planet meanwhile kylo Ren at
the behest of Palpatine is tasked with
killing Rey and ending the Jedi once and
for all from there you get your typical
lightsaber duels Chase's rescue missions
and cameos by beloved characters there's
even some new character revelations and
backstories
kylo basically tells Rey not to pay
attention to anything that happened in
the last Jedi there are filthy jump
treasures so do you offer drinking money
the dead in a pauper's grave and the
jakku desert yeah instead turns out ray
isn't the nobody but actually you don't
just have power you have his power nor
his granddaughter this is followed by
some more lightsaber duels chases and
rescue missions interspersed with a
classic character heroically sacrificing
himself the film culminates in an aerial
battle between the resistance and the
first order while ray faces off against
Palpatine with the help of bad guy GaN
lights kylo Ren ray kills Palpatine but
in doing so dies of course 10 seconds
later kylo brings her back to life
sacrificing himself in the process we
end with Ray taking up the mantle of the
Skywalker's who are you I'm right ray
who
[Music]
right Skywalker if all this sounds very
familiar like you've seen this same
story play out before well that's
because you have oddly enough George
Lucas spells it out in a
behind-the-scenes featurette on the
making of The Phantom Menace
Lucas explains how Anakin is directly
modeled after Luke Skywalker you see the
echo of where it alls gonna go instead
of destroying the Death Star he destroys
the ship that controls the robots again
it's like poetry so if they rhyme for
Lucas the story of Star Wars was all
about how history is constantly
repeating itself there are hundreds of
echoes in the prequels directly
correlating to the original trilogy a
young Anakin blows up the control ship
just as Luke will blow up the Death Star
both guys lose a hand in a lightsaber
duel obi-wan watches helplessly as his
mentor qui-gon jinn is killed by Darth
Maul mirroring Obi Wan's own eventual
demise with Luke helplessly watching
from the sidelines and it isn't just
these plot elements that bridge the two
series together even the visual language
of the prequels directly mirrors the
original trilogy to quote another sci-fi
epic there's one person who took Lucas's
approach to heart JJ Abrams in an
interview for the force awakens Abrams
stressed the importance of repetition
part of the story of this movie is
history repeats itself but Abrams took
Lucas's approach one step further
getting a super meta to the filmmaker it
wasn't just history that was repeating
but the actual films themselves I wanted
to tell a story that was not just
history repeating itself but a story
that embraced the movies that we know as
the actual history of this galaxy this
was not about a nostalgia play it felt
to me like a way of saying let's go back
to a Star Wars that we know so we can
tell another story for Abrams the fact
that the force awakens is pretty much a
carbon copy of a new hope is in and of
itself the point for a pop-culture
savant like Abrams it's not enough to
merely echo the events that came before
instead he has to repeat them and copy
the previous trilogy wholesale thus
raised a stand-in for Luke kylo for
Darth Vader Poe for Han Solo even the
basic story is the same a group of
rebels fight against a nefarious
imperialist army hell there's even a
droid with an important message that can
turn the tides of the
for now Lukas and Abrams aren't the
first people to claim that history has a
tendency to repeat itself this notion
dates all the way back to the dialectic
bad boy himself Georg Wilhelm Hagel in
Hegel's lectures on the philosophy of
history the philosopher famously stated
that revolutionary acts always tend to
occur twice per Hegel in all periods of
the world a political revolution is
sanctioned in men's opinions when it
repeats itself by repetition that which
it first appeared merely a matter of
chance and contingency becomes a real
and ratified existence as proof Hegel
cited the formation of the Roman Empire
seed Caesar first led a revolution to
take over Rome and the Republic and
become its de facto Emperor many
objected to Caesars reign though leading
to a second revolution in which he was
assassinated but in the aftermath this
second revolution only reinforced the
idea that one single emperor was needed
to rule in effect cementing Caesars
initial revolution to destroy the
Republic in a nutshell the revolution
has to happen a second time to make the
first one work the latest trilogy of
Star Wars films adopts this same
philosophy in the original trilogy the
rebels defeat Emperor Palpatine and the
Empire but this revolution is
short-lived in the ashes of the Empire's
defeat the first order rises to power
thereby prompting a second revolution in
the rise of skywalker rey Finn and Poe
lead this second rebellion to victory
finally cementing the rebels victory
that came before it's pretty much
exactly as Hegel himself described the
revolution repeating twice in order to
fully take effect yet in channeling the
spirit of Hegel Abrams has fallen into a
kind of historical trap set forth as an
addendum to Hegel's philosophy in 1852
philosopher Karl Marx stated that
history doesn't quite repeat itself
instead it parodies itself as he writes
Hegel stated that all great world
historic facts and personages appear so
to speak twice he forgot to add the
first time as tragedy the second time as
farce for Marx when a revolution repeats
itself it's not the cement that
reinforces the original but is instead a
mockery of what came before Marx most
famously applied this criticism to Louie
Bonaparte the nephew of Napoleon who
much like his uncle led a rebellion to
seize France and become Emperor Louis
even led his coup on the anniversary of
his
uncle's coronation as the Emperor of
France yet for Marx Louie was nothing
but a character of the old Napoleon
dressing up like his famous uncle
repeating his same populist rhetoric but
betraying Napoleon's own principles for
Marx little Louie
duplicates the cult of Napoleon in order
to legitimize himself but without the
values of his uncle he became nothing
more than a hollow parody history had
repeated but merely as a farce of the
original just like Napoleon 2.0 dressed
up as his legendary uncle without
understanding what made him a competent
leader rise of Skywalker dresses itself
in the nostalgia of Star Wars without
understanding what made the original
trilogy great instead of crafting a new
mythos the film borrows from what's come
before using the exact same plot points
archetypes and even sets but the end
result becomes nothing more than a
parody of its predecessors for example
consider how the rise of Skywalker
treats raised flirtations with the dark
side this is the same arc as Luke's in
Return of the Jedi
but in that film Luke truly did grapple
with joining his father at one point
even succumbing to his darker impulses
yet in the rise of Skywalker this arc is
never fully dramatized Rey has a dark
vision does a little force lightning and
that's pretty much it
Palpatine tries to tempt ray into
succumbing to her darker impulses just
as he tempted Luke but Rey barely
flinches from her morals it's all talk
the arc exists simply for the sake of
repetition it's just as Mark said
history repeats itself first as a
tragedy and then well as this even the
rise of Skywalker's twists are lifted
from the original trilogy the Rey
Palpatine granddaughter reveal is
basically just a watered-down hi but the
Palpatine reveal lacks any of the
dramatic weight of its predecessor in
the original trilogy Luke believed his
father was a Jedi hero who was betrayed
and murdered by Darth Vader a young Jedi
named Darth Vader who was a pupil of
mine until he turned to evil helped the
Empire hunt down and destroy the Jedi
Knights
he betrayed and murdered your father
thus when the big Vader turned happens
it shatters everything Luke believed to
be true it undermined the foundation of
his moral compass his father wasn't a
hero but the villain who betrayed the
Jedi and killed his surrogate father now
let's look at Rey Rey thinks her parents
were junk traders who abandon her so the
reveal that Palpatine is her grandfather
doesn't hold the same emotional weight
it's not like she wanted to be a great
Jedi to emulate her dead parents also
Rey hasn't even met Palpatine yet and
knows nothing about him other than he's
a bad guy and once she finds out
Palpatine is her grandfather not much
changes he's still just a guy that needs
to be defeated her world hasn't been
shattered in the same way that Luke's
was and if anything the Palpatine twist
is more of a revelation for fans as they
recount all the great prequel memes
they've seen rise up Skywalker is filled
with these moments like Louie dressing
up like his uncle the film incessantly
dresses itself up like the originals
repeating word-for-word shot-for-shot
what happened in them but without any of
the context that made these moments work
these moments only exist as hollow
callbacks any emotional or dramatic heft
is entirely dependent on the viewers
relationship to the original trilogy
just look at how rise of Skywalker
butchers Han Solo's most famous line
now this of course harkens back to one
of the most famous moments and Empire
Strikes Back I love you
know that simple exchange was the
culmination of Han and Leia's tumultuous
will they or won't they romantic
relationship
the reason the line has become a
touchstone for the characters and the
series as a whole is because of the
build up beforehand the original films
put in the work with their relationship
to make this single line iconic but in
the rise of Skywalker the lines just
reused as a reference for fans it
doesn't have any narrative value in the
film except as a way to remind viewers
of a movie they feel nostalgic for rise
of Skywalker is built on references but
it doesn't take into account the
hundreds of moments beforehand that made
these iconic moments work the
relationships the characters the world
building that were the foundation to the
original series success and without this
footing these references are just that
hollow and empty a farce of the original
trilogy rise of Skywalker becomes so
obsessed with harkening back that it
even sacrifices logic and its own
characters motivations at the behest of
these callbacks for one how the heck is
Palpatine even alive why bring him back
as the villain in the first place well
let's take it from JJ Abrams the more we
talked about it the more inevitable it
felt that this character who was so
important in the first two trilogies
come back and and in some form that's
the truth in a nutshell Palpatine is the
villain only because he's the villain
from the first six films does it make
any sense that the emperor has somehow
survived being thrown down a reactor
shaft and blown to smithereens in Return
of the Jedi
yeah rise of Skywalker doesn't care
somehow Palpatine returned
[Music]
without any clear logical reason for
Palpatine's return the character feels
like a farce of who he once was even
Palpatine's motivations now don't make a
lick of sense
he sends kylo to kill ray yet when ray
shows up and confronts him at the end of
the film
Palpatine changes his tune completely I
never wanted you dead I wanted you here
this yet again is a direct call back to
the original trilogy where Palpatine
tried to convert Luke to the dark side I
am looking full and two competing
countries must thus the only reason why
Palpatine's motivation rise of Skywalker
changes is to mirror his motivation in
Return of the Jedi and rise of Skywalker
is littered with these inconsistencies
how does Palpatine suddenly a massive
fleet of ships all equipped with
planet-destroying weapons doesn't really
matter because rises Skywalker has to
end with an aerial space battle just
like Return of the Jedi
the rise of Skywalker attempts to
elevate itself to the heights of the
original films by playing on their
success structure and nostalgia but
instead the film becomes nothing more
than a sad copy of a copy it's so
obsessed with harkening backwards that
it never creates an identity of its own
history has now become Star Wars own
undoing but what do you guys think are
we being too hard on the 9th Star Wars
film or is it really just a bargain bin
version of The Return of the Jedi let us
know what you think in the comments
below please don't yell at us and a big
thanks to all our patrons for supporting
our podcasts and the channel execute
order 66 on that subscribe button and as
always thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]